seit ihrem heimatland in die auf die
suche nach ihr lieblicher familie trotz
vielen rückschlägen nun durfte
bin
ob ewald hof nicht steht fest
barbara kroll hat in zwei wahlkreise
flüchten nach wie sie bereits erste mal
wieder zurückholen
ihre geburt comeback
doch immer noch sehnsucht nach dem ort
wo man geboren ist und die kindheit
verbracht ist jetzt komme ich und es ist
der android als gemüse flüchten
damals hieß heimatland armenien / talk
sie jetzt reiste zusammen mit seiner
freundin jetta zurück
[Musik]
die 20 jahre wieder zurück
das ist zurück zu den wurzeln dreis die
mini fremd heimat
[Musik]
von norddeutschland marie seehofer war
héctor barberá ihrem geburtsort die
strecke einfach ideal richtig damals ein
ikarus tours sich kurz vorm an die vom 2
trixi und als fünfjährige mit ihrer
familie als überhaupt messen flüchten
also damals konnte man nicht raus gucken
da waren wir wie was ist der unterschied
das hat ziemlich gesprungen und
ich habe nichts gesehen von der strecke
an sich und die
[Musik]
da hat einfach alles geschriebene und
und und und versucht
zu sitzen und nicht zu stehen das war
absolutes chaos also wir brauchen eine
relative große gruppe und dann war immer
diese orgel zusammen zu bleiben kein zu
verlieren wer gibt eben die hand
wer-kennt-wen mit also was noch war
natürlich ist hört man flac hört man
fliege gehört man warum warum bleibt er
jetzt wieder stehen
es war chaos und überleben also ich bin
ein großer meister im verdrängen
markus nicht zwischenstopp in swinemünde
dauert etwa zu deutschland gehört
spätestens zu den polnisch worte gut aus
sind es nur gut 100 kilometer berg und
barbara geboren ist in swinemünde sind
dann als taube ihrer flucht verbio darum
noch ein paar andere mal erhöht
[Musik]
da
alle legt los
[Musik]
ich habe das eingestehen ist deutsche
und freue mich angeschrieben
[Musik]
zuletzt war scheint das ja ja klar
also es hat sich schon sehr verändert
das heißt es darf das porto
trotz der post archäologisch austria
energie für schweizer adoptiert wort und
witz kalkutta handlichere lieblich
familie finde
bis jetzt ohne erfolg sarah und ihre
freundin natalia halt nur eine hoffnung
sie kam mit der dolmetscherin zu der
michael harrison
das ist therapeut die musiker mit weise
und dort options- verschafft
wer hätte mich so gleitet irgendwie so
tim hein aber nur was war passiert
das ist für mich
in die puschen
[Musik]
jetzt mal ganz deutlich gesagt dass
über der war die dokumente zu finden
das in indien den winter kommen
[Musik]
sie glaubt ihre wurzeln finden aber die
options- und engagiert verschuldet sie
und ohne die wird es ganz schwierig
[Musik]
das aber nicht öffentlicher wagte papier
versuchen findet dass der name thorsten
mutter hat mir kam erste mannschaft und
jetzt ist es etwas beschränkt mit
beschränkter spiele durch ob gott jetzt
kommt noch mit herz mir vorstellen wie
bei mir mit 13
das bewegt mich immer die hohe
produktion von brühl oder verdorben
hatte wurde mir schon vertreten zählt
dass sie vielleicht eben aussuchen
sehnsucht hellweg nicht mehr so schnell
[Musik]
die beide frauen wenn für eine sport der
akustisch dose zum tropfte und zum sieg
über leckerbissen
[Musik]
die letzte die fremde ein und polen
reise barbara und markus auf 904 jetzt
gespart mit ihrer familie auf dem wasser
geflüchtet
ihr geburtsort kolberg ist für russische
und polnische gruppe und sexy und
beschossen wurde
flucht ist nur auf dem wasser möglich
sei
mit klappbarer mit dem oslo san siro
ordnen sie danke aber hallo
lüthis mehr ruhig und die 21 schief für
sich allein aber robuster sind ähnlich
abflug wieder da barbara stamm aus fünf
ich sie einfach an der regelung und
haben tschuldigung das ist meine
untersetzt man nach unten gegangen und
und unter der bahn zu daraus gemacht
ich glaube meine erinnerungen sind doch
eher bruchstückhaft das war alles so
chaotisch es diese menschenmassen und
in der todesangst vergessen menschen ja
allen anstand
ja
also mein erster gedanke ist hoffentlich
muss ich nicht brechen auf dem schiff
und technisch das hinrunden nachdenklich
haltung sei er sagte
[Musik]
also mir schon komisch vor dürfen
fischer protour des bast und damit
sichtbar und markus ziel vor ihrer
reißen die stimme
[Musik]
so kann man echt schräg nach oben
ich dachte da kann man sich alles okay
bittmann gelände auf
die breite zenzi clark jr
exportgeschäfte markus in die
vergangenheit zeige sich flucht aus der
heimat bis heute nicht verarbeitet
pressetext
dass wir sehr schwierig 40 das ist
allemal 17 205 wird wo sie mit der
bohrung dass ich dann durch anderes buch
als musiker ob sie es sich eigentlich
keiner wo sie geboren ist wahrscheinlich
ist jetzt fremd für sie dass sie wie sie
reagieren
auch gut durch die drittgrößte für ihn
dir noch essbar tag im lärm und die
hektik brauche zeit und natalia pause
ich habe ja stimmt
das muss nur sparen zb verbieten die der
hand hätte es auch einstellen er das
thema nachhaltigkeit
und da mal wieder zu
genau davon
sie fordert die zu bauen sie die größte
manko verwalter von der wand
bevor mir auf dass vor ja genau
[Musik]
natalia und seiner kennen sich vom sofa
im pflegeheim besondere freundschaft
geworden ist
[Musik]
ich empfinde es als sehr berührend ich
find halte er die geschichte hat mich
immer berührt und berührt mich immer
noch
und die vorstellung dass man vielleicht
doch noch vielleicht zufällig über für
ihre verwandtschaft darauf hin dass das
begleitet mich und ich habe in meinen
gedanken will mir jetzt so einiges show
sehen wo halt so weit geführt hat wie es
wieder so geführt hätten
[Musik]
was ich nun möglich auf der rasur die
frage stellt sich zeit immer wieder
märz probiert und einem buben so viele
gefragt und überall stone jahr das hwwi
ob ebit stieg auf 6
ein letzter versuch lozano waage sobald
sie wieder zu tisch
[Musik]
zukunft der usc am horizont darf stadt
kolberg
[Musik]
potlatch markt ist sie als fünf jahren
flüchtlingsboot gestanden
[Musik]
das ist jetzt mal speicherstadt das
stand schon aber ansonsten
[Musik]
ich muss natürlich nicht fehlen ist die
achtjährige damals die stadt verlor und
rundhütten polen schied look
[Musik]
ja
danke danke nein mein wissen und meine
erinnerung an die stadt ist ja
verhältnismäßig begrenzt wo ich mich
jetzt fragen erkenne ich das haus wieder
und das kann ich nicht sagen
und wo ich jetzt mühe haben und wo ich
mich frage wie ich reagiere wenn sie
denn sprechen wo ich deutsche im urlaub
und das muss ich dann mal sehen dass das
kann ich nicht abschätzen
du nimmst du gerne und rucksack mit dem
er sich kommst du da rum ich sofort
[Gelächter]
was macht mode und was macht macht ihr
das wenn du hier mit mir bis das
wahlforum er in der zeit dass ich dass
ich ganz wichtig so spärlich ausgefallen
ja und da war selber gefühl für mich
alles fremd ich muss erst mal mehr also
hier ist das ist mir dann auch etwas
fremd nicht aber ich bin gespannt wo du
und ich ja eben was was mich
interessiert ist wie weit die
vorstellungskraft nein die wirklichkeit
stand der verkehr der vorstellungskraft
was habe ich mir ein gebügelt und
wahrscheinlich entspricht der realität
ist das nächstes kleines haus und es ist
das aus was ich in erinnerung
da komme ich mit
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
kalkutta seien im team auf der suche
nach ihr liebliche familie
sie probiert und spirituelle werk in der
schweiz ist im medium wo ihres babys mit
gerät so symbolisch dass ich jetzt die
auf der suche nach den spuren ihrer
wünsche
das ist nix
[Musik]
ein sieg zu sieg
wenn wir das studio oder bäume und dann
hätte ich mystik der polo zum genau
sagen wo sie eventuell für pc medium in
der schweiz habe ich seit das mini
verwandter minimaler mit einem büro auf
der an dass sie kritik an und wir
gewählt heißt das land seine premiere
was war die nervosität was ich begonnen
ist dieser brauch ich mich riesig dass
ich hier und da sehe ich das richtig
dass das möchten wir die treibhausgase
deutsche krise gut gerüstet mister open
sieg heimste ohne hinterhalt
sechs gebiete osterholz coca cola ohne
niederlage
erfahren sie unter
das
das heißt der garten also ich bin hier
zum sinken
obwohl ich jetzt nirgendwo medium
kontakt suchen will
das wäre ist nicht die welt aber er ist
sehr sehr lecker das zeige in ihrem
spirituellen weg begleitet
also ich hole mir das vorstelle dass
wirklich da jetzt mit beraters in der
bin ich maschine nervöser als die will
ich bin der volkssport was was passiert
jetzt
und das ist interessant ich kann
englisch xing bei analytik und denke ich
nicht weil ich wünschte dass man nachts
punkt viele frauen mit berührt
bestätigung habe die bestätigung mehr
zum display soll die frau angeblich das
leben die bestätigung jetzt
[Musik]
die familie kindheit von vielen faktoren
ab
aber im bild mit dem mit die 200 km
stadtrand
[Musik]
barbara macht mittlerweile die erste
schritt uhr ihren heimatort kolberg sie
wird möglichst schnell zu ihrem
elternhaus und jorge obst das logo
der weg führt am strand entlang wo sie
früher mitspielt
[Musik]
das ist so früher war die natur stand
und jetzt ist im kunst- und beton stand
und
[Musik]
kohlberger schütten touristenort beliebt
wie polen und deutschen
jedes jahr mit hunderten tonnen
wir machen
das läuft mir ganz betroffen und
[Musik]
das ist nicht mehr meine heimat und
irgendwo hat man doch immer noch so ein
rest von sehnsucht nach dem ort wo man
geboren ist und die kindheit verbracht
ist und sie haben glück gehabt und die
ganz einfach wie war das schön dauertest
abend und alles jetzt komme ich oder es
kommt zu ihrem elternhaus mag sich
barbara immer noch erinnere auswahl
stück sie zum strand gegangen und ich
habe gedacht ist es einfach geradeaus
geht stimmt dass ich weiß es nicht mehr
ich weiß ja auch nicht ob das haus
ersetzt worden ist durch ein viel
größeres ich bereite mich jetzt da selig
drauf vor weil
dass der schrank nicht mehr etwas aber
das ist natürlich das finde ich traurig
aber naja strand ich daran das
elternhaus kann man nicht ersetzen wie
strand nicht und deswegen ist mir jetzt
bekommen
das aussehen als den stamm zu sehen
also jetzt kämpft sich mein magen
zusammen
leider sorgt am stadtrand tv-spot in die
ok jetzt bin ich ganz fest um sich jetzt
bereits wiederholt gibt jetzt fühlt
dass es sich lohnt auf jeden fall recht
das wahr ist dass runterfährt
erfolgreich
es ist schwierig aber ich glaube wichtig
dass du also das muss ich dir nichts
leckeres machst du glaubst so verstrahlt
dass das passieren konnte auf eigene
gefahr waren ist der platz ja
ich bin sitzen
[Musik]
barbara schmidt marc rotenberg zu ihrem
elternhaus im zweiten weltkrieg
fluchtartig verlassen du weißt
mindestgarantie buch nachwuchs klar
stellt sie sich jetzt ihre vergangenheit
aha
dann muss das ja jetzt die
[Applaus]
es ist
völlig anonymisiert ich habe auch den
eindruck gehabt dass der 1
der eingang nach vorne da jemand ich
stufen auf
eben man ging so rein durch ein gar für
mich und ich weiß es diese diese dieser
ärger oder wie man das nennen mit dem
balkon da war
[Applaus]
guten tag sprechen sie deutsch ich heiße
barbara kohl ich wohne in der schweiz
das ist mal man aber ich bin hier
geboren
die maus in diesem jahr
so ist das alles nur um die ecke nicht
dann auch gar nichts wie der frühere
ferrari familie er leider muss gewohnt
rütli niveau nicht dahin
ich glaube jeder möchte seine kindheit
und jugend wieder seitlich seine
kindheit wieder finden und die dann so
brutal zu ende gegangen ist und dachte
ich mir ja wenn ich dann hier wieder im
haus bin den
kann ich schon wieder anknüpfen an die
jahre die ich verloren habe
aber das kleine heimat mehr als nur noch
fremd das ist nicht mehr mein
geburtshaus das ist nichts mehr dass
anonymous reihenhaus und fertig
das kapitel ist jetzt abgeschlossen
[Musik]
während bordeaux in die heimat für immer
fremd blieb dort in die immer noch linie
hofes vertrauens zu finden
unterdessen fort zwei dinge ein neues
tief am 30
[Musik]
und ja ich bin hier geboren
jerewan bin ich geworden groß gewachsen
bin ich zwischen jedem wann und in
welcher form aber rang auf der karte die
trikots aber ganz viel mehr weiter
harmlos innere freundin chart zeige
mondflüge zusammen auf armenien
unterschiedlich und johanna kartenformat
sagen denn sie bietet sich eigentlich
fahrbahn nach jeder wahl macht freude
hondo ist 7x über seine familie aus
armenien schweiz geflüchtet ist zitat in
ihrem heimatland sie jetzt die
möglichkeit zurück sogar und sage ich
mal nach 24 20 jahre 20 jahre bietet
gesehen dass ich für mich die größte
motivation also für mich ist mir fremd
also ich habe sich sehr stimme aber
nicht braucht der rest der welt bin
klare alltag und zur sache vom an das
mega schöne landschaft hat kurz zugute
lied vor der man keine angst aber die
motivation maxi mini herkunft wir suchen
nicht ein boxer so besser als nie
vergessen
downloads im beruf gemacht als profi
trainierte mehrere stunden am tag viel
selbstvertrauen und messer aus
miteinander mensch macht
[Musik]
armenien gab es schon 20 jahren schweiz
armenien geborene jedermann in einem
haushalt
[Musik]
wir sind mit der familie und karriere
waren nach russland geflogen und vorräte
mit einem fluchtauto nach polen wo pohl
nach bitte nach deutschland wo
deutschland wieder nach frankreich wo
frankreich wieder nach spanien und mehr
glück als verstand in der schweiz
gelandet
die odyssee durch europa zerstreut
aus dem flüchtlingsboot von damals ist
ein erfolgreicher sportler wurde bando
ist unter anderem schweizer meister im
super league wird und auch im ausland
erfolgreich für den traum vom profi box
retten
es geht alles ganz in familie ergreife
stand des cafés in die liga schafft
randow kein kontakt mehr zu seiner
mutter und zwei brüdern
ich glaub damit träume und nämlich quasi
böse gesagt für mich ist das thema
beendet
darunter sind sie zusammen
ihre familie hat er gefunden wurde sich
daheim gefühlt
sehr gern
zwei geschwister die für ihre worte
gehört zur familie erst einmal wenn ich
eine gesehen
du bist sicher würde man also das ist
meine familie auch sehr dankbar erinnert
dass sie so toll
doch trifft welt brachten darum darum
für mich bei neschen muss ich ihnen
danken dass ich das ist sehr schade und
rondo ein schutzwall fairer gemacht ob
sowie freisinns nun ihre mama macht sich
sorgen
ja ersten sich sehr schmal dass sie mit
gott und jetzt plötzlich so eine lange
reise wird neben anderen land aber ich
denke es wäre gut wenn sie miteinander
zusammen
ist die gute hand der flugunfall
miniatur sechs stunden land liegt im
kaukasus network aserbaidschan der
türkei und dem iran
am flughafen der hauptstadt jerewan
mottoshow erwartet vom bus und winkel
ja
nachtruhe zu hans georg ondrasch mal
wieder heute
ob
platz
dass er mitsamt glaubt und jetzt fällt
mir schwer wurde richtige maschine wurde
gemeistert und maxi der richtige freut
mich sehr jetzt sondern muss man
realisieren und die leute jetzt lieber
da er war ein schönes gefühl die schönes
gefühl ich bin noch nicht klar im kopf
aber wahnsinnig die 20 jahren wieder
zurück der schönen saison ja
nächst wuche be mini fremd heimat amondo
bewusst wie viel stimme arminia jordan
york
nach solange das ja ich schön
[Musik]
und 2008 in die vita noch eine wurzel
frauenzell film neues genre geschaffen
es gehört zum geschäftsbereich treten
[Musik]